good morning believe nation today's
message is push war over to you Jennifer
Aniston I was saying the other day to
somebody you know I I think all actors
who are you know maybe and gratefully
may or successful sometimes if you're if
you're you know identified with
something like friends or it's you
almost feel like you're an actor in a
closet always trying it like like I I
want to do more you know what I mean and
and and it's it's always there's always
a little bit of a struggle and a
challenge but I find that exciting you
know what I mean and to keep to keep
pushing myself and to keep challenging
myself and taking risks I think it's
important not to get lazy and stay safe
you know this is a really important
message and one that entrepreneurs
really struggle with because when you
don't have a boss it's really hard to
push yourself to do more entrepreneurs
struggle with pushing themselves out of
their comfort zone because there's
nobody to report to and yes you report
to our customers right if we're under a
deadline or customer wants to get this
thing done by a certain time and you're
you're pushing yourself hard you're
crushing it to go out and get that thing
done on time but if your customer isn't
pushing you hard then it's easy to be a
little bit lazy nothing you're gonna
sleep in all day but you're not pushing
yourself to be the best you can be right
you may be taking a little extra long at
lunch you may be coming in a little late
to the office every spend any more time
just browsing around on social media or
you know just just being a little bit of
a slacker then you should be because
there's nobody to kick your butt there's
nobody to say let's do this because when
you commit to somebody else you're much
more likely to follow through and when
there's nobody for you to commit to as
entrepreneurs we are our own boss
there's nobody we're committing to
besides ourselves we're gonna let
ourselves down a lot and so I think the
the capacity and the willingness to push
yourself consistently hard makes a
difference between a really successful
entrepreneur
and just an average mediocre one and so
how do you push yourself harder when you
are an entrepreneur a couple ideas one
have important goals have goals that you
look at consistently daily that are big
goals that are meaningful that are
important to you remind yourself why
you're doing this to get the energy to
get up and want to push harder every day
to have somebody to kick your butt
whether it's a mastermind group whether
it's an advisor whether it's an online
group something somebody that you're
committing to to say I'm going to get
this thing done I have a mastermind
group that we meet every month and in
between you have a weekly phone call
with somebody in your team and you're
pushing each other because if you come
to that next meeting the next month and
you didn't do what you say you're gonna
do the group starts holding a little bit
of a flame to your foot to say like
what's going on you've been saying
you're gonna do this but you haven't
come on let's get let's get in shape you
don't want to come to that meeting and
not have done the things that you said
you were going to do and so that
accountability is really important for
entrepreneurs and then three we've
talked about a ton on this channel the
environment and the routine it's so easy
to get up for one day it's hard to get
up consistently it's hard to keep that
energy level high and so build whatever
gets you pumped and excited into your
morning routine consistently so whatever
you start your day were think about what
makes you come alive again if it's
watching the video or reading a book or
viewing your goals or listen to some
music whatever it is you know for me
it's being around famous entrepreneurs
successful people and seeing what
they're doing yes their strategies
helped me that's part of it but a big
part of it just seeing people going off
doing amazing things makes me want to
push myself harder they push me to do
more because the people around me aren't
really pushing me to do more and so
whatever gets you excited whatever makes
you feel like you want to push a little
bit harder build that into your daily
routine as opposed to having it randomly
happen because you turned on YouTube at
four o'clock in the afternoon build it
in every day so you're pushing yourself
so the question of the day today is how
do you push yourself how do you keep
yourself accountable to doing the things
that you say you're going to do and
reaching your ass
to a potential what do you do leaving
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout at the Cathy cashmere from CCC
inspired calm Cathy thank you so much
you're picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you enjoyed it
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso hey believe nation for those of
you who want a little more content on
pushing yourself harder I think you'll
enjoy these special bonus clips well I
think you know it can be really anything
that gets you interested I just always I
just want to make sure I'm gonna be
challenged the whole time because I know
if I'm not given like sort of obstacles
I don't really I get kind of lazy I
don't really engage in the way I want to
so if I know something's gonna
constantly be throwing challenges at me
not in like I want to have fun you know
that I always want to enjoy what I'm
doing but something that is gonna be
that's part of the fun I think is
getting also you know the challenges of
it I took this like big risk and quit
school
I quit the one thing that I was like
that was like surefire and went and
became a model and it got really bored
really fast and didn't love being a coat
hanger and then I became an actor which
was like a coat hanger that talks and
and then and then I ultimately like came
full loop it came back around and and by
the way when you talk you're generally
not even speaking your own words you're
speaking somebody else's words and
trying to make it sound really real and
then I keep full loop around and and and
started looking at technology again I
started getting interested in
sort of get interested in engineering
and started really getting interested in
solving problems solving my own problems
and then solving other people's problems
and what the value of that is and so
whether it's it's technology or
philanthropy or actually even performing
or being an actor I started to make it
about solving problems and I think that
that's the that probably the single
biggest thing that as an angel investor
I look for in entrepreneurs is people
who genuinely want to solve a problem a
real problem a problem that exists not
just for themselves but sometimes just
for themselves and then it and then it
then it sort of turned into this wave
effect that solves other people's
problems and sometimes by trying to
solve your own problems you're solving
everybody else's problems because
generally if you want to affect the
world you have to change yourself first
everybody tries to go out and change the
world by changing other people and other
things but the real way to do it is by
changing yourself and sometimes making
those really uncomfortable choices to go
up against everyone in your life that
you look up to and take that risk to go
be a model or go do this thing that
nobody else is doing basically what
success meant to me was the opportunity
to be useful so somebody else you know
might entertain me as a as a choice but
it also meant that I could I could use
that event of a success to do something
different than what was expected I could
go to another genre I could go to
another kind of role I could go from the
success of witness to the opportunity of
Mosquito Coast right and and people say
wait a minute you know might not be the
best career choice in his half
I don't have to make the best career
choice I have to make a choice that will
challenge me and be interesting for me